japan is home to high quality artisanal
calligraphy and makeup brushes known as
kumano brushes made entirely by hand
they've been produced in just one city
for nearly 200
it's
years
[Music]
[Music]
tokusen lives in kumano where he's been
making brushes for 50 years
there are only about 19 traditional
craftsmen like tokuzen
yet they produce most of the entire
country's brushes
this keeps tokuzen pretty busy
intensive 12-step process
what ultimately determines the type and
quality of a brush is the hair that is
used for the bristles
prices for kimano brushes can vary
some go for as low as 10 us dollars
cost is partially determined by how much
hair is used but also something else
[Music]
but how are brushes at such different
price points used
[Music]
here's someone to explain whose entire
profession
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but in order to make such high quality
brushes traditional artisans like
tokuzen are subject to rigorous training
before becoming a master
for five decades now token has been
sitting cross-legged on the floor for
several hours every day sometimes his
legs will go numb yet he's far from
tiring of his craft
[Music]
[Music]